all right dr nash has helped so many
people achieve their weight loss goals
today she joins us with three inspiring
weight loss success stories
dr nash you have been transforming lives
all across the valley
and one of the lives that you have
transformed is your own
we're talking 80 pounds over what 10
years ago how did you do it
yeah we're talking about 80 pounds 11
years ago and i did it by finally
focusing on the damage underneath
instead of the weight problem so all my
life i was told
if i ate less and moved more i would
lose weight but actually i was
struggling with insulin resistance and
fatty liver
that would not let me lose the weight
like i was told i would
once i started aggressively going after
those issues that's when everything
changed and that's when i lost it
and you've lost it you kept it off you
look amazing and today i'm very excited
because we have video testimonials
of some of your clients and we're going
to start off with catherine
let's take a look at catherine's story i
went from a size 14 to a size 6
in 30 days i no longer suffer from
fibromyalgia
and i no longer suffer from depression
wow what i love about katherine is we
see a physical
and also a mental transformation because
she no longer deals with depression
issues
yeah so catherine lost one of her
children which is hard for any mother
um gained a lot of weight as part of
that depression but with my program we
were able to get her from a size 14 to a
size six
in 30 days like the woman completely
transformed from the inside
out that that is just amazing and you
kind of see it in her face you see
just you see some happiness in her face
which is wonderful
and now we have laura's story take a
look at this when i started with dr nash
i weighed over 300 pounds and i was
pre-diabetic
since being on a program i lost over 130
pounds
and i no longer have that pre-diabetic
threat wow
laura's story is incredible over a
hundred pounds she lost
she lost 134 pounds this is a 58 year
old woman right so this is somebody that
thought that it was
menopause that was driving her weight
problem when really it was a whole
different set
of hormone issues plus she had fatty
liver as well
so it's not menopause for a lot of women
driving this weight problem it's a
hormone problem
but not menopause i love how you you dig
deep you find the issues you find what's
going on you fix the problem
and now we're gonna watch this is
sarah's video take a look at sarah in
just three short months of losing weight
i've lost 52 pounds and 35 inches off my
waist which is where i wanted it most
another one i feel i feel like you see
their happiness in their face and sarah
is an amazing story with over 52 pounds
on sarah
not only did sarah lose 52 pounds sarah
lost 52 pounds while uh
while she was with me overall she lost
98
pounds so again this is what the program
does i get the problem corrected for you
i teach you how to do it and your body
just keeps delivering the results you
always come to
us with a special what kind of special
they have for us this week
you bet so normally to have a talk with
me and find out if the issues are what i
deal with it's 97
but if people mention that they saw me
on las vegas now with jc
we've actually set aside 10 spots where
you can one get the evaluation for 9.97
but you can find out the root of your
problem how to properly fix it and more
importantly
how do i fix it for good but you got to
go to the website that's the best
place that you're going to be able to
schedule the appointment